there are a lot of people at boost at
this convention right now we're
competing to get attention it's a fun
kind of way to get into subway and sort
of look at subway in a new way is it
still in d maybe not South by Southwest
is the legendary music film +
interactive conference held annually in
austin texas since 1987 reasontv went to
the interactive festival this year which
has a rich history of popularizing hip
and game-changing technology like
Twitter Foursquare and foodspotting but
is South by Southwest came to a close in
2014 there wasn't a singular app or
website that was taking the digital
world by storm now this could mean we've
all been oversaturated with tech lately
or perhaps South by Southwest has lost a
little of it Cindy street cred major
brands are able to come into South by
Southwest with a serious funding all
right and that funding empowers them to
do things that get people's attention
Joshua Jake Vaughn is the austin-based
founder and CEO of Connect too good a
start-up website that helps connect
people who have items to donate with
charitable organizations that are
looking for goods but doing so can be
extremely difficult for a small
bootstrapped startup web app like
connect to good especially when we're
competing against the likes of these
major apps like uber coming to town and
it's not just major apps like uber that
Vaughn has to compete with for attention
it's also corporate sponsors like AT&T
Chevy assurance and Deloitte and it
doesn't stop there small startups also
have the New York Times to contend with
and half human half robots and Canadian
software companies and argentinian tech
companies in fact South by Southwest
Interactive is so popular now
practically everyone wants to push their
new hip tech product here the place' is
a new product from subway that the users
are existing materials like flat bread
you know there
to create this awesome new pizza and its
really really good philly daisy layne
harris is a senior technical director at
360i the advertising firm that came up
with the brainwave controlled video game
a display for subway we really felt like
because this is an innovation for subway
this is this is taking a you know a new
step for subway and since South Bay is a
spirit of innovation it seems like a
really nice match the targets perfect
you know these these are the folks that
really enjoy subway products you know we
know our consumers and you know it's
it's a it's a fun kind of way to get
into subway and sort of look at subway
in a new way now it's not as if the
bootstrap startups are placed right next
to the dynamic and engaging subway
display but this kind of setup shows how
far south by southwest has come since
Twitter blew up in 2007 what we've seen
with the evolution of the of this
convention over the years is just we've
gained so much notoriety so much
attention and with that comes a
competitiveness to kind of cut through
the noise so where the startup companies
now you'll find them in the startup
corner so the idea is that if you're a
scrappy startup and you come to the
startup corner over here you're gonna
have somebody come by your booth who may
never ever have come by your booth or
been interested in your company i should
say unless you were here at South by
Southwest that's Andrew vanden town the
founder and CEO of the startup 10 square
calm a crowdsource production studio
that has found a little bit of funding
already and is exhibiting on the austin
convention center floor we're separating
ourselves because instead of trying to
take we're giving back and i really feel
a lot of companies out here are saying
hey we built this widget pay us money
for this widget it's really cool and a
lot of it is innovative that's super
cool but there's a lot of stuff that is
an innovative and new and fresh but not
every startup gets a booth in start-up
corner remember vond with connected good
calm we found him hustling outside the
press room a few floors up a lot of
times we find that
no you have to be vc-backed or have
serious funding to get a booth there get
a table to get in front of press and so
I have to like always think creatively
about how do we address these problems
my problem today being how do I spread
word about connect to good and you know
immediately what I think of well let's
just go hang out in front of the press
room let's see who we can talk to
because I believe in the idea I believe
in what connect good is doing we've done
amazing work so far in the community and
we need to further that work but the
only way we can do it only way we can do
it is if we capture the attention of the
greater population and that's why we
need the press and marketing to help us
see what Vaughn is doing is turning the
New South by Southwest structure on its
head by going straight to the people who
will give him attention he's cutting
through the noise which may be the most
innovative way to approach the next
south by southwest in 2015 for reason TV
I'm Paul Dietrich